c'est un phénomène peu médiatisé dans le
monde du sport qui toucheraient des
milliers de personnes 5 à 15 % des
athlètes amateurs des yvelines se
seraient déjà dopé une tendance étudié
par le professeur alvarez à l'université
de versailles saint quentin en yvelines
chaque année le scientifique traite
également une vingtaine de cas au niveau
judiciaire dans l'ouest parisien
oui on a peut-être eu un qui veut plus
d'affaires dans le cyclisme
probablement mais peut-être que c'est le
hasard j'en sais rien mais aujourd'hui
on a là quelque chose qui est plus
inquiétant c'est le dopage
non pas dans un cadre de compétition et
dans les salles de musculation sert cole
et prend les gens prennent des dopants
pour faire leur musculation pas
forcément dans un cadre compétition pour
développer leur masse musculaire
aujourd'hui les sportifs amateurs se
fournissent directement sur internet un
danger selon le professeur c'est très
facile d'accès mais quand on l'utilisons
c'est vraiment parce qu'on prend on
al'impression comprendre la baule inoni
la testostérone et en fait quand on fait
l'analyse je peux vous garantir que au
moins la moitié des cas on n'a pas la
molécule dedans et quand on a la bonne
molécule parfois n'a pas le bon dosage
nous le risque est attendue parce que
quand on connaît pas le dosage on peut
faire une overdose de phacélie pour
lutter contre ce phénomène le professeur
jean-claude alvarez à trouver une
solution les prélèvements capillaires
les produits dopants peuvent être
retrouvée dans les cheveux pendant
plusieurs mois alors que les tests
urinaires ne reflète que 2 à 3 jours de
consommation et le sens 24 heures faut
savoir que dans le dopage
il ya des substances les anabolisants
pour ne pas les citer que l'on va
prendre plus tôt avant la compétition
les prendre pendant la compétition ça
aucun intérêt ça n'apportera rien on va
les prendre avant pour développer la
masse musculaire
donc forcément pendant la compétition il
n'a pas on n'en retrouve pas puisque on
arrête de les prendre par contre on en a
appris pendant six mois avant donc
l'analyse capillaire va tout simplement
permettre de remonter dans le temps et
d'aller voir que la personne a pris ou
non des anabolisants en 2015 seulement
onze mille tests ont été effectués dans
toute la france au niveau amateur chaque
contrôle coûte en moyenne une centaine
d'euros